Trump had some thoughts from Bedminster
yesterday on the indictments so let's
get the Trump version of events now and
react to that
this is called election interference and
yet another attempt to rig and steal a
presidential election
more importantly it's a political
persecution like something straight out
of a fascist or a communist Nation
don't forget this persecution is being
done by the same weaponized agencies
that for seven years have been running
illegal psychological warfare campaigns
against the American people from the
Russia Russia Russia hoax to the no
collusion Mueller Witch Hunt
to impeachment hoax number one
impeachment hoax number two the fake
dossier
paid for by the Democrats how about the
fake dossier remember that one the FBI
Twitter files and so much more
that's an example of the it's just the
the frustration of kind of pulling apart
a trump speech where there are certain
components there that are valid like you
know aspects of the Russian
investigation as we've covered on this
stream before were pretty bogus and a
lot of ways we're completely bogus yes
the fact that the FBI and the justice
department as we've already talked about
have been sloppy at times seemingly
politicized or unfair seems to have
opened up
the opportunity for this kind of
obfuscation from somebody like Trump and
I don't know if you have any thoughts as
to
how we move forward from this this spot
because it's one thing to say you know
we gotta stop handing out the free
passes but then how do you do that in a
way where
you're not just
acknowledging the political reality and
seeing that you're going to inflame you
know a large segment of the country over
this perceived unfairness
yeah I look uh it's a tall order I mean
you know the Department of Justice is an
utterly rotten and compromised agency uh
I know I've been throwing a lot of stink
at him but look I mean this is this is
the agency that gave Jeffrey Epstein a
slap on the wrist they caught the most
prolific child molester in the history
of this country and gave him a slap on
the wrist um and the plea agreement that
they reached with him the the
non-prosecution agreement is one of the
most corrupt documents that I have ever
seen in my life
um and and they handed that out you know
uh
why because well he just knows a bunch
of famous people and some of them are on
his plane to uh uh
his his private island so so can you
redeem an agency like that I'm not sure
I think it's uh worth adding watching
you know Trump you go through his list
of uh you know grievances as Festivus
lists there for a minute he's absolutely
right about all of that and of course
it's larded in with a bunch of
and things like that I'm looking at that
and the one thing I want to say uh Zach
and uh Clark is you know what at least
we can say Libertarians are not to blame
for this Libertarians routinely get
blamed for you know moral breakdown
because you know people smoke weed now
instead of drinking themselves it to
cirrhosis uh you know where we don't
care about kids we don't do this or
we're irrelevant blah blah blah but it's
like the one thing that is good to say
is that a Libertarian perspective on the
the size scope and spending of
government the role of it and whatnot
you would not lead to this kind of
outcome where you have two equal and
opposite forces uh you know that that
command fewer and fewer adherence from
the American population of Republicans
and Democrats these are two parties that
have been around since the before the
Civil War and they are locked you know
like uh Professor Moriarty and Sherlock
Holmes in a death Embrace constantly
falling over reichenbach's Falls and
neither of them can get to that place
that I think Clark is talking about
where you say you know what in the
interest of the country in the interest
of something other than the most base
and banal and vulgar self-interest that
I need to win the next news cycle or the
next election I am actually going to do
the right thing and start to reform a
government you know that has single
digit ratings I think Trump is is guilty
I think he's wrong the way he acted is
wrong and that should be changed but
what we need to take away from this as a
way to actually create a different
system and a different framework that
does not just say you know what uh you
know it it puts the American electorate
in the uh in the role of you know of
little kids watching their parents beat
each other uh there are no cops that are
coming like this we need to we need to
be removed from this kind of spectacle
and put into a different situation
altogether or create that situation
it seems like we're caught in a vicious
cycle to some degree and this you see
this in it's a dialectic with no
possibility of synthesis exactly and you
see this in countries that have high
levels of corruption where all if all
the top officials are constantly either
breaking the law or at least kind of
pushing the the boundaries of legal
Behavior then their political opponents
come in and they kind of with some
justification
take them down legally and then it flips
back the other way and we're you know
we've seen it the pendulum kind of
already swinging back and forth from
Clinton to Trump and now in the Republic
in the just yesterday the Republicans in
the Senate have announced that they're
you know uh they have these documents uh
that may or may not prove that Biden was
involved with uh Ukraine and some sort
of bribery scheme and so you can see
this back and forth pendulum swing uh in
motion and what you know I'd like to see
Libertarians somehow disrupt that uh but
I I'm not sure you know what what the
next steps are in order to stop that
that pendulum swing can we run the uh
Vivek ramaswamy clip he has an idea this
is my commitment
I'm elected the next U.S president
to Pardon Donald J Trump for these
offenses in this federal case and I have
challenged I have demanded that every
other candidate in this race either
signed this commitment to Pardon on
January 20th 2025 or else to explain why
they are not pardons have obviously
played a role in presidential crimes in
the past
what role do you think they will play if
any in this situation
well this is this is uh now we're really
in the uh
uh out beyond what anybody can predict
here
um in the Twilight Zone so there are two
possibilities besides uh I would say
that you know vivec pre pardoning a
president is outside the realm of
possibility since he won't be president
but
um but I I would not rule out the
possibility that Biden pardons Trump I
don't think it's likely maybe it's
something on the order of one in ten or
one in 20 uh but you could imagine Biden
essentially treating this as an active
statesmanship the way Nixon uh Ford did
with Nixon
um and then there would be the subtext
right because everybody knows that uh
the the preferred candidate uh for the
Democrats in the next election is Trump
they want Trump to to run and if they
thought that you know this would enable
him to stay in the in the you know in
the race and get the nomination
um you could see that sort of checking a
couple of boxes for them again I don't
think that's likely but I think I
wouldn't rule it out the other uh even
more sort of uh science fiction question
is um could Trump pardon himself if it
were to somehow be elected
um you know if he's not yet been
convicted by the time you know he he
gets to be elected president and
inaugurated if that were to happen he
could just order the Department of
Justice to to terminate the invest
investigation but if he had been
convicted but somehow still manages to
to win the presidency then the question
is can he pardon himself and guess what
we don't know the answer to that
question thank goodness it's never come
up in real life but having kind of
poured over the relevant language uh
just the other day I think it's within
the realm of possibility uh and not a
completely Preposterous reading of the
relevant constitutional language and you
know I I don't even know what's going to
happen if we get to that point I mean I
I just think we're gonna we'll be
tapping these three the the Strategic
cynicism reserves of the entire country
at that point so hopefully it won't come
to that hey thanks for watching that
excerpt from our conversation with
Cato's Clark Neely about the Trump
indictment for the full conversation
click right here for another clip from
that conversation click right here and
come back every Thursday at 1 pm for
more conversations just like this